well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages in the next half hour or
so then we'll see what's making the
headlines with the observers chief
leader sonia soder and the telegraph's
chief political correspondent
christopher hope they were with us from
now until just before midnight welcome
to both of you as we listen there to the
prime minister and joe biden let's see
what's on the front pages then shall we
the times looks at mr johnson's first
white house meeting with joe biden the
headline britain lines up to join
american free trade pact but the
guardian says the pm's hopes of a uk us
trade deal dashed with the reports that
the biden administration is focusing on
other priorities
that story also on the front page of the
eye in what the paper describes as a
devastating blow for the prime
minister's vision of post-brexit britain
according to the financial times the
international energy agency is lobbying
moscow to send more of russia's gas
supplies to europe
the telegraph hears the french president
emmanuel macron is considering putting
france's u.n seat at the disposal of the
european union if its government backs
his plans for an eu army
the metro speaks to a woman who claims
she dialed her gp surgery
673 times before she could even join a
queue to speak to them
and the sheffield star carries tributes
to three children who were murdered at a
sleepover last weekend your memories
will live on at school forever
so sonia soda and christopher hope are
here now and clearly lots of breaking
news coming out of that meeting uh in
the white house uh and many of the
newspapers already picking up on the
lack of progress if i can put it that
way on a trade deal for example the eye
no deal with the us on trade this
prospect of joining
another trade group but let's deal first
of all with christopher how
disappointing this would be for the
prime minister not that he wouldn't
expect it i guess
well i think there's been a lot of good
tics uh as beth rigby said there in your
report in the special relationship it's
back on track maybe after a wobble a
concern about confidence in it post the
speedy afghan and withdrawal it might
have been a great bonus that will have
more development on this trade deal and
certainly it seems that the air has gone
out of it uh with donald trump um being
replaced by joe biden the democratic
president and issues there he's
concerned about northern ireland and and
he made made quite clear in response to
the beth's question at that that um that
huddle there in in the white house so i
think you know it would have been nice
to have got there have been side deals
done on scotch whiskey imports no
tariffs on that since the summer last
september there was deals on scotch beef
but there's no question that there's a
lot that's not done um brexit you know
is a ten-year project probably to get
right
a big shame i think for the pm it looks
like he's saying that interviews he will
not get any deal done by 2024 the likely
of next election um so the idea of a
brexit dividend is not going to happen
uh at least not immediately with the us
but certainly in terms of relationships
and after that deal there on on
intelligence with australia um
uh and uh and uh others you know i think
that there's a lot to say that with the
u.s should say that there's a lot to say
there's a lot for the special
relationship more than seem to be there
in august yeah similar theme for the
guardian sonia um you know everybody's
quoting boris johnson telling our
political editor beth rigby that well
you know they negotiate very hard uh the
americans we're going as fast as we can
uh we heard also joe biden there saying
it's going to be discussed they'll go on
for a private meeting after that spray
as they call it with the journalists
there some invited journalists in but if
we move on to the daily telegraph
um the suggestion that the uk may join
the u.s mexico canada trade club as
hopes fade for a loan deal with america
this falling to the new foreign
secretary liz truss who's already raised
stalled negotiations with u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken when they met
in new york during the u.n general
assembly um the pa news agency
suggesting that miss trust questioned
whether that position is tenable in the
long term and has considered other
routes to improving trading ties with
the united states so i mean you know it
feels a sort of backdoor way of getting
somewhere um with these nations of north
america what do you reckon
well i think it's very
optimal from the prime minister's uh
perspective uh a trade deal with the us
was supposed to be the big brexit prize
it was the key plank of the prime
minister's vision uh for post-brexit
britain and our trading future and i
think this is essentially that
post-brexit vision colliding with
reality
lots of trade experts said at the time
that the prime minister and vote leave
were far too bombastic about the
prospect of a bilateral trade deal with
the us the uk is a pretty small economy
um standalone as things go the us has
got um bigger fish to fry as i think um
you know
the prime minister said
and um so it was always going to be
extremely unlikely that we were going to
be sort of um way ahead in the queue for
a trade deal particularly with president
trump out of the white house so i do
think that you know that the talk has
moved to the prospect of the uk trying
to join um an agreement that already
exists
between the nations of north america the
us canada and mexico it is definitely
suboptimal i think at the end of the day
when we take a step back from this it
does sort of raise questions about what
we were trying to achieve
uh with brexit because obviously one
post-brexit option available to us was
to sort of stay part of the single
market the eu but to leave the political
institutions so to stay economically
aligned and the truth of it is is that
that vote leave told us that this was
about taking back control but you can
never strike a trade deal with other
countries particularly when you're
negotiating with a block far larger than
yourself and i come back to the fact
that the uk by itself is a modest sized
economy compared to these big trading
books that we're talking about you can
never negotiate a trade deal and not
give up some sovereignty in terms of
regulatory alignment that is the price
of a trade deal so the the question
facing close brexit britain was always
do you want to align in a regulatory
nature with the eu or do you want to
align with the us and there's all sorts
of issues around food standards in the
us for example chlorinated chicken is
just a sort of thin end of the wedge
which means that i think actually the uk
public isn't going to be that happy when
it finds out what's signing up to a
trade deal
with the u.s mexico and canada really
means you know of our values when it
comes to the labor market food standards
etc are actually they lie much more with
our neighbours on the continent
and um just very quickly christopher uh
we saw those pictures of kamala harris
and the
the prime minister you know sharing a
look at the view um will he go away
really satisfied by this do you think
given the ticks we've talked about the
extra commitment to the climate change
budget for developing nations
this lifting of the of the travel ban on
brits going to america is that enough do
you think
it's certainly something as a former uh
american uh national until 2016 when he
announced it boris johnson will have
will have felt that quite quite quite
importantly you know why can't we have
this uh this steady flow of people to
and fro across the atlantic for me it is
kind of continuity obama uh obama said
didn't he back in 2016 would be at the
back of the q fred trade deal it looks
like you know joe biden is his vice
president is saying saying as much now
now he's in charge of the white house i
think there's i think that they've done
the best they could i think it's been
difficult uh since the afghan withdrawal
but i think they have got that you know
they're moving towards uh
you know a way of working i i do share
someone's concern about a deal with the
us mexico and canada i don't think the
choice is offering was a fair one it's a
false choice to say we sign up to all of
the all of what all of the uh different
levels of standards in all that in those
three countries not quite the same as
that but i think um yeah i think uh it's
more to work on
um food shortage fears averted sonja um
what's the deal
so the government um it's emerging
tonight has struck a deal he would have
thought that gas shortages would have
had such a big knock on him on the uk's
food supply chain but it does because
co2 is used in so many forms of food
production and food transport it emerges
tonight that the government has struck a
very short term deal with one of the
major co2 suppliers cf fertilizers
financial support for three weeks to try
and get co2 production back on track but
i don't think that that's going to
answer the longer term questions about
the sustainability of co2 production
given the gas shortages are forecast to
sort of last a lot longer than just the
next couple of weeks absolutely uh co2
and all the things it does who knew but
the fundamentals are the gas prices are
still going up and effectively
householders and these failing
businesses now as we see will will meet
the costs of that christopher
and so will taxpayers we don't know
where the full at the full cost of the
deal signed by quasi-quattang tonight
it'll be millions and we're all paying
for it don't forget we have got this
issue of the review of the of the energy
price cap of the first of october and
then in april next year council tax
bills going up the national insurance
increase the special wages caused by
that we're in for a very difficult cost
of living a few months i think and that
that will define i think the period
going into the christmas it should be a
lot harder more expensive just to live
in this country not easy yeah absolutely
inflationary pressures globally not just
here that was the warning today wasn't
it thank you both very much indeed